sorry
um those Title II grants are 27-month
grants so right now currently we have
Grants open for the 21-22
and then the current grant for 22.23
the 2122 will expire September 30th of
23. and then we'll have the 2223 Grants
open for another additional year those
will expire September 30th of 24. in
addition to this summer the 23 24 grants
coming out so you've got three years
worth they range from 9.5 9.6 million
dollars um this year we allocated 9.8
million dollars in Title II programming
those program funds can be utilized for
mentorship for professional development
for any type of um
program for new Educators or Educators
new to a school Educators that are new
to their position perhaps the funds can
be utilized for all of those purposes
and then on our website we have a link
that shows the distribution and what the
allocations are across all the leas for
different for their different amounts
for example Manchester's allocation for
this year is 1.375 million so you'll see
that that tends to be because it is our
largest tends to have the most or the
largest allocation in comparison and
then the rest will be
it's a formula grant so it's based on
a formula set aside by the federal
government in relation to census poverty
data Title 1 students and that type of
thing so in the FY 22 allocation 2122
that we're in right now
yes which has to be expires on in
September 23 of 24. so the current grant
for so just to give you an example for
2020 2021 we distributed funds and the
programs lapsed
1.385 million so 1 million 395 000 was
not spent collectively amongst the leas
in Title II
so what's done with that money that's it
goes back to the feds it goes back to
what to effects goes back to the U.S
department yes if that money is not
spent by the program then it is returned
so currently in for the 2122 Grant which
is going to expire or ends the period
performance and September 30th of 23
there's about nine hundred thousand
dollars that's not budgeted so what that
means is we have allocated the funds to
the schools they have gone in and put in
their activities into the grants
management system we have approved those
grants 900 000 has not been budgeted
they have not said we're how much what
you know what they're going to do with
that nine hundred thousand dollars
so
if we look at our current balance as of
today
2.7 million has not been spent so we
have 2.7 million to spend down by
September 30th of 23.
is it likely you will spend it down or
not that's on the program side so that's
the leas if the leas spend it
um and then we have an additional Grant
when does that be spent by September
30th that in this year of this year yes
if we're getting to the end of the
school year right now correct
and there's I mean definitely summer
programming but it it with 900 000 of
that not being budgeted you know they'll
it gets makes someone like me a little
bit nervous because I'm like so let's
spend this down let's spend this down
and addition if you're looking at the
current grant for this school year which
will expire
next September
um and that was the information that I
sent out oh wait kind of reverted sorry
I gotta pull up my grant balance on that
one give me just a moment to reset it
um but I think we're at about 2.6
budgeted and we've distributed 9.8
so that's quite a bit they have to spend
within a year
representative cascadden question so
there's no redistribution of funds no
is there in Title One
title one they can carry over their
funds but it's limited so they might be
able to carry over service percentage
one year
um but yes also Title One funds could be
utilized for a similar purpose okay it's
no carryover and choose title two no no
there is not
when we allocate dollars to another
program like Career Technical education
we have what we call a maintenance of
effort correct and it does that is that
applicable to this program as well not
for title two not for title two the
supplement versus a plant is an issue
though
so I I will be be um just clear on the
the requirements
if the grant so if we had the five
hundred thousand dollars and we are
Distributing those funds out the less
would have to spend down that allocation
or that Grant before they could spend
their Title II funds
oh okay yeah so we've distributed for
this year the 22-23 school year funds
expiring September 30th of 24. we've
distributed 9.8 or allocated 9.8 million
so far our leas has spent down 24 of
that which is about 1.2 million so um
5.2 million has been budgeted so you
figure about 54 of the funds have been
budgeted
and
and the other 46 percent
have not been budgeted at all
representative Tanner
I have a couple of questions thank you
for taking them um because I really
would like to find out more about this
when you say it's not been budgeted is
it not budgeted by the Lea or by the doe
uh by the Lea so we have allocated the
money we have given them the 9.8 million
dollars they have submitted their budget
to us saying this is what I would like
to spend it on we review it and say okay
it's allowable and then we approve it
and so we're looking at only
um you know 54 of that has been
submitted to us we've approved it and
it's ready to be spent down so uh is
that like um writing a grant I mean is
it
when you say budgeted it it is funny to
me that you know that
working on school budgets but I know
that when money is available usually
there's a grant that that the local
school writes and is that what you're
talking about it's a little bit of a
similar process because it's a formula
fund they they automatically get that
allocation so we you know for Manchester
for instance it would be the 1.375
million so we give them that allocation
what they need to do is write out an
activity that explains what they're
spending it on and how much they're
spending it on and they have to just
break it down into categories with their
budget so we'll look at that and say oh
okay for a professional development for
science for example for our science
teachers
um we're going to you know give them a
stipend of this amount we're going to
pay a trainer to come in and train so
they give us their budget for that
activity we review it make sure it's
allowable within the the grant program
and then we say okay good to go and it's
approved and you're ready to spend your
money right so they don't when you say
we give them the the 1.9 you're not
really giving them that you're writing
it rates on a reimbursement right you've
actually set it aside and set up uh the
parameters uh of how they apply for it
and then if they meet your standards
because you're the ones that say whether
they meet the federal standards by so
you're really interpreting the federal
standards for the state
um in some respects right yeah says the
pass-through as the pass-through entity
our responsibility is to ensure that the
funds that they're um what they're
spending on matches with the
allowability that's in federal law right
so
how many
um
how many of these do you fund and how
many do you refuse
so I would say for the most part
the leas have a pretty good idea of what
I mean these funds have been around for
quite a while so they have a pretty good
interpretation of what they're going to
spend it on so I don't I think more of
what we tend to look at with regards to
allowability is like period of
performance particularly with Title II
they cannot try to get reimbursed for
something that's already happened so
they can't offer professional
development then submit it to us for
approval after it's happened already in
the past that's an example when we would
say no we can't approve that because
Federal requirements require it to be
submitted ahead of time approved within
the period of performance so
percentage-wise though how many are
approved and how many aren't I don't
think I could answer that I don't think
we collect the metrics on that part of
it but I will say I mean we do have the
how much is submitted to us and then
what's approved so we're able to see the
allocation of 9.8 million
5.2 has been budgeted and 4.9 has been
approved so that process of going back
and forth with the Lea to ensure that
that
the way that perhaps they describe it
meets the allowability that piece of it
I mean title II is one of the easier
um grants to interpret as far as
allowability goes and how much does the
when you say the grants are like 9.6
million 9.5 million how much of that is
given to the department as
administrative costs so the 9.8 is the
entire allocation to the leas the grant
that's coming in from the federal
government to the sea is I think I want
to say it's about 10.6 so we might get
in a 9.8 going out so it's just that
that difference there's a percentage
that were allowed
and there's requirements about what we
can spend it on so there's a certain
percentage that has to go for
professional development targeted
towards
um administrators and principals there's
a small part for administrative costs
for us to do the grants management and
then another percentage that we can use
for programming and I think that last
time somebody spoke
um I can't remember who it was they
talked a little bit about some of the
um contractor work that's happening
across the state with helping out Rural
and small school districts with
mentorship and so that would be an
example of a program we would use our
Title II funds to go and help support
those types of so the activities
so just you know this your last question
this month we up about 10 so far okay
yeah
so if the doe contracts uh company to
come in to do
uh professional development for schools
is that money then
taken out of the monies that are for
example if Manchester wanted to do their
own professional development but you had
contracted services for mentorship they
submitted a grant for uh their own
program their own local program
outlining it and and you come back and
you say well we have we have contracted
this service for the if we would still
approve their activity we would it's up
to local control how they're spending
that funds as long as it's within the
allowability regardless of what type of
programming we're doing at the state
level
we would still approve that activity
however if it's state funded that's
where we have to get a little bit
careful with the supplement versus the
plant because if we're setting aside a
certain amount of money
that is specific for mentorship and we
have an uh an Lea apply for those funds
we would just have to ensure that they
ex completely expended those state level
funds before they then spent down their
Title II funds
okay representative woodcock
thank you chairman good morning
um just a couple quick ones uh and I
wasn't here the last one so we may have
already answered the question well the
900 I have to representative why
although 900 000
um if you say is still hanging there at
this point does doe at some point send
out a notification we have as much left
is there anything there multiple
constantly throughout the year um on a
monthly basis are uh one of our program
managers that oversees really the the
money side sure constant messages like
you haven't submitted your report we
have those leas that it's been a year
and they still haven't submitted a
monthly report to be reimbursed for
their costs and so it's for constantly
giving the nudge please please please
submit those reports and fall to that
part of it
um about about how many you said this is
a formula of Grants so it's
automatically there how about how many
leas don't take advantage of it
I would say oh that's a great question
I could look at a balance here
I would say they all for the most part
submit some sort of budget with the
exception of maybe a handful okay and
the last question if I make you're going
on three well she went 10.
yes sir yes last one
um just a final question the the um Bill
218 is the early educator professional
development the title two I should be
clear title two is all professional
development correct okay thank you thank
you chairman you're welcome next
represent Belcher
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
being here for this um I just wanted to
clarify from my understanding just
as far as the money part is concerned so
what this bill is actually doing is it's
establishing a grant fund and the money
the 500 000 yearly that doesn't come
from the federal government that comes
from state taxpayers but it's matching
Title II funds is that so the way I
interpret it is that
you know there is part in there about
the local match or the title to match
the the part that I guess is not
included is that those
those
um local funds or those State funds
would then be required to be spent down
before they could touch any part of
their Title II funds I don't think when
that this was drafted that was
necessarily
um known
but that's the piece we'd have to be
clear about is that anybody applying for
the grant
um if it was if it were to be
established they would just have to know
spend these funds down first before we
could put in your allocation into the
grants management system for your title
two funds I mean they could still
possibly budget those funds but we
wouldn't be able to turn around and pay
out until they completely expended any
of the local or the state funds so if
let's say they're using their state
and their local funds to match that
state Grant those would both have to be
spent down before they could touch the
federal funds
thank you and just actually how that
helps a lot just to clarify just a
little further in in a hypothetical if
this program according to this bill were
in place today and we had all this
Federal money that we're talking about
that needs to be spent this program if
there were money left and it would
actually be an impediment to accessing
those federal dollars before because
we'd have to spend down those State
funds first before we could touch them
right
think that
Partners from
saying that it's at the local level so
the Lea would be the one that would have
to spend it down but I would actually
like to double check that with the
federal Partners to ensure that entire
500 000 would not need to be spent down
before we could touch the 9.8
um but it's my understanding that it's
at the Lea level so that they couldn't
so I for example when we talk about
Manchester I would actually advise them
if I were
um a part of their administrative
committee or you might want to really
think through whether it's in the best
interest because you know 1.375 versus a
very you know small chunk of a five
hundred thousand dollar Grant across the
state
it's pretty small I mean
and it doesn't really clarify how we
would prioritize
who gets the funds
represent dry did you have your hand
I did thank you Mr chairman thank you I
think you just answered my question was
there isn't really a a way to disperse
this that's written in the bill but
clarify for me please is is this kind of
like the cart before the horse because
it says that this money the 500
000 would go to match the title two
whereas you're saying we'd have to get
the the state Grant first instead of
that so how would you match the title
too correct you don't know what okay
thank you that's just what I wanted to
know
so I I do have a follow-up to the line
of thinking we've been looking at right
now so we allocate through we
appropriate the department of properties
500 Grand
and if that money isn't used
according to this bill any unused funds
shall lapse back into the general fund
so and I to assume then that seeing the
fact that the
the department has 250 000 to the 500
left
and this money is specifically
appropriate for local master plan for
staff development and recertification
according to the bill
could we then spend any of our monies
which are coming title two wise to this
state for staff professional development
and if we allowed that money to lapse
back into our general fund
following my track here not no
okay so we have appropriate X number of
dollars to be used for professional
development from the state level for
local development use of those dollars
but if you maintain at the end of this
year annual year or the biennium money
left in that Grant fund are we then
allowed to use Title One Monies
in the local levels if we still have
local level money available at the state
level that's the question I'd have to
get clarification from
the U.S Department of Education is it
are they considering because similar to
what I think representative Belcher was
saying that is it
at the sea level or the Lea my
understanding is at the Lea level all of
the guidance that is put out by
um and looking at what's written in 2cfr
it's really at the local Education
Agency so it's my understanding the
supplement versus the plant would be on
that end
but I would want to double check just to
be sure that it's not at the sca level
because if it were to be we're in
trouble yes it wouldn't be worth it I
mean 500 000 versus
10.9 million bucks no
represent cascadden
um for me knowing how the amounts of
allocations for Title II it would seem
to me that five hundred thousand dollars
would be better spent in building Aid or
inadequacy
so I I'm having a hard time buying it
and and following up that 1.2 million
dollars that's uh reimbursed
um how often how shown does a district
receive reimbursement once they've had
this project approved it's completed how
long does it take before is it done on
their quarterly payment or so reports
can be submitted monthly so
um districts that are I would say vary
on top of their payment process and and
processing everything they submitted
right at the end of the month they turn
around get reimbursed within a within a
few days to a week
um most of them are set up for automatic
payments so they immediately get that
but not all districts are quick to turn
around so it really is dependent upon
them if they turn it around pretty
quickly and input
um that on a monthly basis for
reimbursement then that they get it
pretty quickly
but they do have to wait until they've
paid for the service they can't they
can't submit for something before
they've paid for it and it's similar for
us on our end of it when we do the
drawdown on the FED side we have to have
expended those funds before we can
submit for that drawdown on the federal
side
okay represent Tanner asked her 11th
question really
really about this on some level
um
can they use this money for college
credit reimbursement in other words uh
if we're retraining for Early Education
yes so if they uh if the Lea decided
that they wanted to pay for um some sort
of training or if it's you know a
college level course so they could
choose to do so
the way the training sometimes occurs
then correct me if I'm right or wrong
here is that
teacher X Y and Z those three teachers
want need some professional develop in
this area so I take them out of the
classroom
and I hire substitutes that go into the
classroom the payment for the substitute
teachers comes from
represent Cascade and says yes yes title
two yes they can pay for the substitutes
they can pay for the courses all the
materials
um any of a stipend that might need
perhaps they're taking it after hours or
they're doing extra work on the weekends
or something like that they can pay for
a stipend
um for that any type of travel fees
all of that is is allowable are the
reimbursement for these costs based upon
local negotiated agreements or is there
a set amount the department has
reimbursement or substitute we'll pay X
numbered hours it may be different for
each district to the negotiated you know
it's whatever they're paying the
districts
so one is paying 65 a day that's how
much would be reimbursing including some
stipends of some kind correct that's all
based at the local level well I mean we
do look at reasonableness so if we get
some sort of request and it's you know a
thousand dollars a day for a substitute
we might take a peek at that and say can
you give us some more information as to
why but we've never seen anything quite
like that thank you represent Luna thank
you very much Mr chair so um I I just
want to try to get a little bit of
context for for this so so
currently I think you said the state
distributes about 10 million dollars in
Title II is is a title 2A title 2A yes
title two eight uh grants and um and
about 1.9 of that might go to the
Manchester School District
1.375 1.3 sorry 1.3 or one 1.375 and
then they will have
um about 37 000 of that that will go
um to the Equitable Services portions in
that part of it not not really Theirs to
choose from but then after that the rest
sure so so again just trying to put that
in context of approximately a 10 million
dollar uh Title II grants about
um about uh 13 to 14 of that goes to the
Manchester School District they've got
about eight or nine percent of the
states
um educate about eight or nine percent
of the state students so that's that's
you know it seems Seems and it seems
reasonable correct and the formula so
the question is uh if if if on top of
the approximately 10 million in federal
Title II another 500 000 was to come
from the state how much of that do you
think would be going to Manchester how
much of that would might be going to um
you know the the where school district
and um do we think it's really out of
the question that they wouldn't know how
to spend that money or that money would
get stranded or or something like that I
mean it sounds like Title II is still
going to be the Lion's Share of of of
the the funds that that local school
districts expend on professional
development so I was just wondering if
you could sort of you know if Manchester
is getting 1.375 from Title II how much
you think they might get you know
proportional speaking out of the five
hundred thousand and how much would a
smaller District
um you know
you know
conceivably get you know proportionally
out of the state portion of the current
so looking at the proposed legislation
it doesn't really say how to distribute
the funds or how to base that so I I
actually don't know how you would do
that let's say if it was even done
proportionally though if it's done
proportionately
if we're doing it if we were doing it
based on the title II formula
versus per pupil I think that would
determine a difference because the title
II formula also has the consideration
for you know poverty data title one
student sure well not to not to boil the
ocean but just finger in the air back of
the napkin back in the envelope
engineering
um uh design Manchester would see maybe
fifty thousand dollars out of the out of
the half million maybe I mean I'm not
sure oh well I mean maybe it's let's say
they got all of it let's say they got
all the all five hundred thousand
dollars of it went to Manchester is it
inconceivable that a school district
with 13 000 kids and how many teachers a
thousand would would not be able to
apply half million dollars in
professional development over a thousand
teachers in one year I mean are we
really thinking that this money's not
going to be used or somehow is going to
be stranded
um you know particularly in the context
of how much every District including
Manchester including where including
Hopkinton is spending on professional
development using Title II
so and and especially that that this the
state requirement here as as outlined in
the legislation is so specific with
regards to teachers very early in their
career because Title II was not specific
to that is that correct so it certainly
is included so Venn diagram wise the the
this program would be inside the title
II bubble but it's very specific I mean
I mean is is it even conceivable that
that a district even one District even
Manchester spending all of the money I
always look at Patty when I was saying
Manchester I mean it depends on the
district it depends on their plan I I
you know with title two we can't tell
them what to spend their money on so
they can look at all the allowabilities
within Title II and they prioritize what
their needs are so they're saying you
know this is our priority versus that so
that's a local decision I I really just
look at what what are the facts as far
as you know when I look at the dollars
look at the time frame and look at
um
the the you know Federal and and
requirements with that piece of it so
with Manchester specifically you know if
we're looking at okay they would get the
entire theoretically get the entire five
hundred thousand dollars currently in
their title 22 23 Grant they out of the
one point
you know three million dollars
um 131
000 has been spent
and of course they have an entire year
and you know three months to use that up
but that's just a given it's more likely
proportionally Manchester would get more
like 50 000 not all of the the entire
engine and all we would look at is just
making sure oh they spent that down
first yeah excellent and then they can
move on to their it just doesn't seem
hard to me well we we are talking in
some generalities here but when I'm
reading this bill
on line 18 it says development Grant to
mass local school district or Title II
funds
if if we're going to run into this
question whether we can match with Title
II money so we have to spend down these
funds first before we can use title two
monies I think we got a problem in the
wording of this bill and it's going to
need some work
so so Mr chairman it is an early bill
yeah yeah so so potentially would would
eliminating the words
to match local school district title two
funds
and then pick up with the word utilize
so it would so in lines 18 and 90 it
would read professional development
Grant utilized for the purpose of
fulfilling the professional development
activity that's one cleanup maybe yeah
but then you have to deal with rules and
the rules are not it's not clear here on
line 13
where the Department's person will
develop rules to implement this grant
program how long it's going to take that
to occur and
I I just see a lot of things which
aren't clearly well defined what those
rules specifically are going to be
addressing rather than a broad statement
which we've been asked not to do that in
our legislation
represent cascadden
um I think I think this bill would need
a lot of verbiage
changes as well but in line six
um use the funds for or to orientation
support and I would put or Mentor
Educators
um definitely read just
um redefine what an early educator is
um
new in the profession and I think it's
described in one two three
um not necessarily a grade level and
then line 18 the grant
um would have to be expended by the
local schools prior to
moving to the allocation of Title II
funds
plus my question now is
if I'm going to set up a mentor program
and these funds are going to pay the
mentor a stipend
for that mentoring process
how sustainable is this
once you set up a program and you have
five or six teachers who are trained in
mentoring so you can use Title II funds
from the pre say the previous year to
train people to be mentors because it's
a different
you know skill set than coaching
and and then you get this money
to to implement that
how do you sustain it is it a one one
and done or is it a
you know is the intent of this bill to
be 500 000 allocation on an annual basis
um so that would have to be clear
because I would think districts
if they think it's a one-year thing
or they're not sure if the next year or
subsequent years are going to be there
for that particular program
um we have a lot of funding sources like
that so I just would question that
because to have a good Mentor program
you train your mentors and then you know
they
of a process which defines how the
grants are going to be uh sought in
terms of dates and times and is that an
annual process is a bi-annual process it
doesn't say
um I I think this bill needs a lot of
work before we
we move it forward that's my position on
it I like the idea of mentoring teachers
I think that's wonderful I think we need
to do it I'm on the teacher shortage
committee that's a positive thing but
um
I think we've just come down with so
many particular issues we're trying to
say everything in one page of a bill and
there's a lot more to this
um we found that out when we're dealing
school building Aid and really never
defined
a lot of the issues dealing with the
application process as Amy Clark is now
determined we need to rewrite that to do
it properly
and the other thing I have a question on
is the rules for the local professional
development master plan
are those developed by the board or the
local I don't know
in in in this in this the way it's
worded in this this document here right
well the local well the state has a
master plan and then the local has to
have a master plan and that's what your
professional development is supposed to
be all tied to your professional
development but it reminds me to ask
another question if there was money set
aside by the state specifically for
mentoring programs of
new to the district or new to the
profession teachers
would that
be enough separation from the title two
so that they could be used
simultaneously
do you know because that would make
another difference I don't think so
I think it when it's well something
that's allowable within yes yeah it's in
the it's in I'm looking at the two-way
discipline and it's it's got teacher
mentoring in there and mentoring of
course yes very valuable all I want to
speak to is operationalizing the
legislation as it's written and
potential
um decisions that maybe need to be
thought about as far as allocation
um you know is there priorities
that the study committee has looked at
certain areas perhaps that
those funds need to be targeted towards
school districts that perhaps get a
small
pretty small Title II allocation perhaps
or is it schools that have
um you know when I think of we have
school districts that have a lot of new
teachers consistently
would it be better served towards those
districts because they end up doing a
lot of that mentorship and training and
then those teachers end up going
to other schools and they you know I've
talked and talking to some of those
superintendents they're like we just
kind of embrace that's who we are we
have a lot of new Educators is better
served that way I think there's just a
lot of questions
maybe that
um the title should be changed with the
specific intent of schools applying for
money if they wanted to initiate a
mentoring program within their District
I don't know if that
and then I don't know if it can be
sustained through Title II and I would
suggest maybe a name change as well new
educator professional grants instead of
early educator because early educator in
the education World indicates
um preschool teachers preschool or Early
Education early childhood education
what kind of accountability does the
department have that the professional
dollars used for the title II for
development at the local level are being
used appropriately so we do that first
initial review so a a an Lea will submit
their
activity to us describe it give us their
budget for what they're spending it on
so we review it initially for that
allowability once it's approved and then
they submit you know once the activity
has been complete they're submitting a
monthly report that that reimburses them
for the costs associated with that
activity and then through monitoring we
have the fiscal monitoring Bureau
Federal compliance does monitoring and
then we also have programmatic
monitoring that is done so we have our
staff that will go into a district and
say okay it said you know in your
activity you're going to spend this
these funds on this can we look at some
of the evidence to support you know the
implementation and it could be meeting
minutes it could be training manuals it
could be a variety of things so if we go
and check that out are there further
questions representative luno and then
representative Lucas thank you very much
Mr chair I just um I I'm I'm
worried that maybe we're um we're we're
micromanaging this too much and and
um you know I I think it has been
at least in other committees that not
not
um not standing committees but study
committees and things that um that that
really we try to operate legislation at
the 30 000 foot level and rules comes
down more to the the ground level and
and I think the the way this bill
um comes out is that it it it does
um I think provide the department with
with at least three
um standards with which to establish
this type of program and and I I guess
my question to to you would be does the
department collect data that would give
them the ability to look at an
application and determine whether a
school district has
um has has in fact
the need to provide this sort of
professional development because they've
got a lot of
um
new teachers teachers that are new to
the uh to the profession and and I guess
I don't know what what if the if the
department has access to this data but
anecdotally from my time in on the
Hopkinton board
um uh we got a lot of teachers from
Franklin
and and I'm not sure and I'm looking
over Becky Wilson because she was she
was employed by the district
um I don't think we had that many
teachers that who were new to the
profession in Hopkinton
um because they were already they were
always coming out of Franklin three four
five sometimes 15 years into uh into
their profession so I'm thinking a grant
program like this Hopkinton probably
wouldn't even
wouldn't even apply uh for it but I can
imagine that there would be a lot of
districts across the state who would
find that this would really be
beneficial because they're seeing such
turnover that um that that providing
some sort of training and development
for for their new teachers might um
might result in teachers staying there
for longer or maybe even for their
career and I've been told that that that
that's a good thing for um for for
school districts not to have you know
such dramatic turnover every year it's
good for school districts it's good for
Education good for learning for the
students
um good for stability for the families
that they're that they're serving I'm
just wondering do you think the
department has access to the data that
would help them number one write rules
so that we don't have to legislate at
the at the ground level and number two
be able to
rate an application to uh to determine
whether a a district would have need
under this program
um definitely I think we could do that
and also I just wanted it shows on line
23 within the first year of working in a
new school or District so I think that
even schools that may not have a uh that
may be recruiting experienced teachers
they could I mean apply technically for
funding to support teachers that might
be new to the school or District
um the department would be able to go
ahead and set rules and look um and do
it you know Based on data and based on
evidence
um to support programs that might might
be better served by the funding in
addition to most of the you know
application or competitive grants that
we do put out we you know have our
priorities identified in addition to
then you know other criteria that is
preferential but for the most part if
we're looking at setting these are our
you know priorities for these funds and
then any applicants would need to meet
those priorities so we could set the
rules and then make the application
based on those priorities such as a
school with a high percentage of new
teachers or some sort of metrics like
that we could establish right thank you
Melissa when this was put together this
bill was the department ever queried as
far as what how would you help us or
could you help us in developing the bill
were you involved with it I believe we
did Supply a fiscal note
first how about the language itself
within it um I need to check with Steve
Applewood he might have been consulted
but I think we both agreed on the name
for sure that the new educator was
probably a more appropriate title
representative like us thank you
thank you I just want to make sure I
understand the full consequences of this
bill
so if we do vote for it then the the
money that goes in must be expended
before the title to before they have
access to title 2 money so that's my
first question is that correct so the I
want to double check that with U.S
Department of Education because my
understanding of of two CFR is looking
at the Lea level so when I read this I
interpreted that the Lea would need to
have that spent down before they would
touch their Title II funds but now that
it's been brought up I want to double
check before I 100 say yes we can go
forward without having to completely
expend the 500 000 before we could touch
our the state level Title II funds
the flip side of that is if we don't
pass this
the school districts could use the title
to money for mentoring
and correct other stuff as it is now
Title II title one
um title one specifically if we're
looking at Title One teachers they could
use that professional development wise
for that title three
um would be for teachers that perhaps
are English language learning for our
English language learning students and
any kind of training or mentorship
around that piece of it
um you could use
um what was the other one I was thinking
of
think that that might that might just be
those too
um but again it's you know at the local
level absolutely to determine what their
priorities are and where they see you
know because they have to look of course
across all of their
um various programs and their needs of
their district and look at whether it
makes sense to just carve out the fund
specifically for mentorship I I
completely understand that that it's
hard for them to you know make those
choices at times
okay thank you thank you Melissa
um we have another bill which we have to
do some discussion on are there any last
questions which for yes representative
just just the point I think you need to
realize that the study group is around
uh beginning teachers and retaining
teachers
and this also as Melissa pointed out
does talk about the retention question
because we heard testimony that when
teachers move from one District
experienced teachers move from one
District to another they still need a
mentor because it's a whole cultural
thing that that new teachers to a
district need to understand the
procedures the policies the forms
they've got to fill out so I think that
this bill does uh address that issue too
as well as a new teacher
and I apologize I just remembered what I
was thinking of a special education fund
so idea funds can be used for mentorship
of new special education directors or
special education
teachers that are maybe even new to that
I just said an email come in from Dr
Appleby he was not consulted on this
bill
represent dry thank you Mr chairman just
a total change of
subject there was in the Senate hearing
uh talk of a contract that we currently
have with the state of Colorado for
virtual mentoring
um that was 469 thousand dollars where
does that money come from and who does
that affect so that um fund uh that
contract is with uh of course it's going
to be a teach United it's a nonprofit
organization that focuses specifically
on small or rural schools and helping to
establish systems helping to establish
mentorship and it's not targeted
specifically for new teachers but really
creating those cohorts among small
schools um it could be Charter Schools
as well so they've come into New
Hampshire they've created this cohort so
that it allows you know particularly our
smaller schools that may not you know
when they have a professional Learning
Community there might just be a few
teachers within that school so it allows
them to connect and have a much larger
opportunity to go through you know
implementing different systems what are
the issues that they're experiencing how
to's how um
administrators can connect with other
administrators so it's not so uh I guess
isolating but that particular program is
funded through our title to state level
funds
um particularly and that is
um targeted to any school that wants to
participate so we we kind of put that
information uh and uh
that not application because they really
didn't have to go through an application
process but it was like you know this
program is available if you're
interested in joining on this program so
we started off with I think five or six
schools previously and then we've grown
to 17 so I know there's several schools
in Claremont that said you know we
definitely want to join in and be a part
of that and so we're adding in for the
next cohort I think we're up to about
17. yeah
so does this that get kind of charged to
the account of the school no no
so our state level set aside that we
have
um I think it was mentioned earlier you
know there's a 9.8 million that goes
um directly to the leas and then there's
that you know art and title our entire
allocation is
um I think 10.6 somewhere in there and
so we take the funds that are for our
state level activities and we use it for
activities like that thank you
thank you very much again Melissa I
appreciate your taking some time to come
out and help us with this today sure one
last thing we also use the state level
set-aside Title II funds for
paraprofessional training so we've
offered it up to paraprofessionals
Across the state or anyone that's
interested in becoming a
paraprofessional so we have our training
that we've done for um this past year
we're going to do another year of that
so that people can come in even our
administrators can come in and meet with
potential candidates talk a little bit
about their program and their schools
and things like that so it's not just
for teachers we target it towards
paraprofessionals as well
thank you so let's now switch gears a
little bit and go into
213. if anybody has to take a short
break go ahead and do so
um Tom Dolan you're you're standing in
for represent cordelli today so you'd be
sitting right here
been contagious so nobody has to worry
a good morning for the record Diana
Fenton and attorney with the Department
of Education
um
I think having the amendment to the
definition of social media account
would help to flush this out a little
bit so I think if you keep the first
part
um
of SB 213 I'm looking at it on the
website lines three through seven and
then add in this paragraph that I wrote
yesterday
um
I think that way they won't conflict
with one another
um
section one which it which amends the
definition of social media account as
found in 189.70
to clarify the definition shall not
apply to platforms used for
demonstrating evidence in student career
development
so that amends that definition
and then this
section two
you replace that so that's effectively
lines eight through fifteen you replace
it with what I provided to you yesterday
and that would amend
189.66
and instead of creating a new section in
189.66 I simply added that language
um
to
the enumerated
provision so if you look at 189.66
Roman numeral four
sorry five
um it's a lot of numbers running around
here
um each local Education Agency shall
develop data and privacy governance plan
which shall be presented to the school
board for review and approval so the
thought was if it's part of an ongoing
plan that the district does and gets
approval from the school board you just
add it to those enumerated Provisions so
we added in F
which would be
students participating career
exploration or CTE May with parental
consent
register for technology platforms so so
is that the same as Waters
um but but it's 5f instead of instead of
a new Roman six
very similar no I think it's like
it's not identical where's the
difference the concept is similar so
Waters was amending wedding 189.70.
no 189.66
. in watersville assist the students
program of studies Amendment
I'm talking about 12 37 minutes program
of study no I mean I think it's very
clear but now we're saying it's an
approved program of study approved by
the CTE the instructor Etc okay yeah I I
think that's anything yeah that makes a
lot of sense yeah
but I mean it's essentially on the on
the same um same concept as as what
Waters was talking about I
and then putting it in 5f as opposed to
creating a new Roman six correct yeah
yeah that makes sense
we didn't want to call it out as its own
section for fear that it might
contradict with five and so we wanted to
embed it in five but uh representative
Leno to your point it's very much just
taked on the we took the concept and we
just massaged it a little bit and
figured out how to make a little
stronger
yes
and so you do believe in section one
belongs NW
because I have two amendments coming one
which
last part it should be it yeah and
another one coming with the second one
as he came to us from the Senate
with section two that you did I would
suggest keeping in section one I think
it it
um strengthens the definition and it
would alleviate any potential that it
would conflict with section two
okay
Amendment here wasn't that different
about cheers
I have it yes
so it's 16 19 h
[Music]
M thank you mine basically took
um that second part the waters Amendment
but it added two things
um
it says
hang on and that it's not social media
and then it defines social media for the
purposes of six this section means the
social networking website that is used
by a Kerner prospective student
primarily for personal Communications so
basically it was to hone in on or zero
in on
um
things like
Adobe that kind of thing but not
specifically not things like LinkedIn
because then that puts the students
at risk for all of the things that
happen with
social media that we've seen where
people get Shadow banned and all kinds
of stuff because they held the wrong
opinion on something and so to get
students
used to using a platform for
um career readiness
or if you're looking for a job which
then in the future they can be Shadow
banned on and then not get jobs because
they
posted something that wasn't bad but
that wasn't according to current
um approved ideas and we don't really
want to get students
started down that line
so they would still be able to do
take the Adobe tests all of that kind of
stuff still get real badges not the
LinkedIn badges which nobody pays
attention to but real badges and all of
that stuff they just wouldn't be able to
do social media in whatever form that is
that was
so it was kind of taking it all of the
things that we did in the subcommittee
kind of trying to take into
consideration all of those things making
it clear that yes they can do these
things even though currently they can
just to make it clear that they can but
that it's not to include social media
which was a concern amongst a number of
people
by putting social media in this section
alone already in 1956
this amount of act that terminology
ended this whereas that traditionally
has been held back before 289-70.
this is a community
I think it has the potential to yes
student
social media notice it's called
improvements
such as the school approves social media
as part of the students program than
that then they could do we we should use
our mics
if a school decides to approve a social
media platform as part of uh School
students
um
program
then
unless we exclude social media they'd be
able to use that under
the other section
representative cascadden
um but it does require parental consent
so
some parents would just say known some
would say yeah I'm fine with that
yes
but it doesn't have with the other
amendment that represented
representative elevated you again not
the general but I appreciate it thank
you attorney
um attorney general there you go
I think you have the word approved
program of studies in there which I
think is very important that the program
be approved as part of that CTE career
exploration or CTE program
which the amendment you crafted does
have that terminology in there
I like the approved but who approves it
well they have Regional commissions that
are taking care of the ctes
they have to approve much that also the
sending school if a receiving Center is
going to offer credit for a course that
has to be approved by the sending
District so I imagine the saddening
district is very much involved with this
as well
any further discussion on we have
several amendments possibilities here in
front of US Representative
pardon me
represent a hall thank you
representative Lucas could you just I
was trying to follow what you're saying
they talk about LinkedIn where does
LinkedIn fit into this
LinkedIn is a social media platform
and it would not be covered under my
Amendment okay specifically
so in subcommittee or actually in
committee here as well we heard that
this is all about LinkedIn
that you're saying no LinkedIn right
because there were numerous people on
this committee who found all kinds of
issues with LinkedIn and specifically
did not want that to be there and so
that's why I tried to
cover what
the CTE people were trying to cover
without pulling in LinkedIn which was
what a number of people on the committee
objected to they follow up with it so
when we heard Pam McLeod and Jeff beard
both speak about this they were all
about the LinkedIn and we talked about
the data the privacy and all that that
was a concern where Pam said that we she
needed six months to figure that all out
the data privacy and all that stuff
so I'm not sure we ever heard no
LinkedIn because we heard this is a
LinkedIn bill
right I mean the first part
not the amendment that the CTE wanted
but the first part yes but then they
agreed that there were problems with the
LinkedIn
and so that's why I took that out
because that does leave the students
open to the whims of the social media
platform
okay one more follow-up yeah so I didn't
I guess I didn't hear that the problem
was with LinkedIn specifically but I
thought when we talked about this they
both agreed that the senator Waters the
original the original one that we heard
was good they both agree that it made us
stronger which uh I think
that same language here somewhere
um it made it stronger and then they
said about that privacy part so I
thought the recommendation coming out of
the subcommittee was let's
stay with that original language but the
data privacy you had offered to work
with Pam you know for for September or
whenever to work on the data privacy but
I never got the sense that LinkedIn was
going out the window I thought we heard
from both of them and even on committee
that LinkedIn was really what this is
all about I'm just gonna so that was how
I walked out of this subcommittee okay
well there were quite a few people who
walked out differently which is how the
Belcher amendment ended up coming to be
because that was specifically against
all social media
okay
okay any further discard represent
Cornell I I was under the impression
that the whole point of this original
bill being put in was because the ctes
were having a problem not being able to
the students to be able to show their
skills that they've accomplished while
they're in the CTE program and being
able to carry it with them when they
were out of the the program and they're
going on to further either their
education or apply for a job or whatever
so if we take that out we're taking out
the entire reason why this bill was
proposed in the first place so the ctes
were requesting that this information be
allowed so that the students
are getting credit for what they're
accomplishing and their skills
and that that reflects
what I have in front of me here from Dr
Beard
from Jeff and he said I agree and if
it's possible amending RSA 18966 would
address the issue we've discussed of CTE
teachers and students finding it
difficult to access industry recognized
credentials assessments and Industry
standard tools such as Adobe Pro and
SolidWorks in the CTE programs that's
communication which we have and was Jeff
beard you know as is he worked with you
on this amendment
that you know I you the one that I
drafted last yesterday yes I sent it to
Jeff he's reviewed it I didn't have a
long conversation with him but he's
aware of what what we drafted yes
Rick yes
um the CTE part of it was the waters
Amendment which is what is in my
Amendment it's the part that lets the
CTE do all of those things with with all
of those places where the kids are
getting trained on like if they have
training on Adobe they can do the they
can use the platform they can take the
test that is a permanent
um badge that they have the badges that
was one of the things we had discussed
the badges in
LinkedIn are not really recognized by
industry this allows them to do the ones
that the CTE was asking for
um and so that's why that's all in there
because that's what they came that's
what they wanted
I think they were specifically asking
for LinkedIn because it follows them to
their job afterwards when they apply for
to say I've learned this skill so I I do
think and going to the CTE advisory
committee that I'm on I hear the CTE
centers for the past two years
complaining about this recent law that
was put in that prevented them using
this and it's keeping the students from
using what their skills when they're
going further on so this specifically
was put in to do what it's now going to
do with
um attorney Fenton's Amendment and
um Senator Waters original one and I
think if you take out social media
completely it doesn't do anything of
what the ctes were asking for
represent Belcher
thank you Mr chair just to reiterate
from the subcommittee some of the
testimony that we did receive on uh this
Bill yes this bill colloquial
colloquially known as the LinkedIn bill
was in fact designed to give students on
to LinkedIn and other such social media
sites for the objective of obtaining
digital badges for job seeking and
whatnot we also heard testimony that and
in current law there is nothing
prohibiting
uh programs of study within ctes or
schools from doing industry recognized
standardized testing for things like
Adobe the only thing they're looking to
do is to get onto LinkedIn wherein you
can take not industry recognized quizzes
to obtain uh badges that show
theoretically that you have some level
of knowledge in a certain topic and this
is used for job searching and whatnot
and yes you're 100 correct I believe
that is what CTE was trying to do was to
get people on social media and Linkedin
that is exactly why I crafted my
Amendment because I think that is
totally inappropriate for about a half
dozen different reasons we heard
testimony that this would subject
students to the terms of service of
third-party social media sites that
means whatever whims they may have
they are subject to those terms of
service I specifically brought up ideas
of the idea of hate speech if they have
something they say that and kids say
stuff
the the testimony we received is they
want teachers to be able to direct
students on how to not violate hate
speech regular rules in terms of service
I don't think that's something we should
be worrying about in school we have a
constitution We're Not subjecting Kids
to third-party terms of service we also
heard that this opens up kids to
potential Predators because we can't
monitor the private
um activity of uh private messages and
there's also some data privacy issues
when it comes to this so that is exactly
why I put my amendment in place that
would totally preclude not industry
recognized standards not CTE anything
just the use of social media
isn't your your train of thought here
overriding the authority of a parent
you know this says with written parental
consent
and from the school district side it's
an approved program of studies so you
have both the school districts saying
this is what's going to be done with
this program and you have the parents
saying you Johnny Hess or Susan has my
you know consent to pursue this using
this technology platform so I think that
what we've done through the amending
language that the attorneys both of them
have put together here for us I think it
captures everything that we need to
capture
if I may just respond to that
um we also heard testimony and I would
agree there is nothing prohibiting
students if they want to from from
obtaining these social media platform
um credentials and accounts on their own
outside of school you don't have to do
this through a school curriculum all you
have to do is sit down and take a quiz
on your computer and you earn the
digital badge so if a student has
received the requisite training in a in
a school curriculum to do that they can
simply go home log on and get the batch
but this also has language within that
bill which is saying as used as part of
the students so so if they're at school
they can do this it's part of their
approved program with parental consent I
don't see a problem with that
further discussion
okay uh anything else on on this bill
yeah Rick Rick I think um I heard you
say that that you have an amendment that
preserves section one and then create
second takes the attorneys and plugs
that in in section two that's coming
into it somewhere along the way right
right and that would be Roman 5f per the
language that you had in your your
um the draft that you put together with
Diana and that that came from and it had
the word Diana approved program yes yes
all right correct yeah yeah
representative yeah no so we've heard
from perhaps they're like us we've heard
from representative Belcher on their
amendments we have not heard from
represent McDonald who also has an
amendment here so I to complete the the
look okay representative McDonald and
speak to her Amendment on this too thank
you okay go for it thank you I'd like to
say that the discussion we've been
having about the amending language that
you Mr chairman worked with attorney
fending on I think it's important to add
a proof program of study because that's
saying that the program itself is
approved by the school but what my
Amendment would address is how the
social media platform would be used
because like it has been mentioned
there's data privacy concerns with
third-party contracts the school board
or the school administration would not
have any control of these third-party
contracts but they can in their school
say how these platforms should be used
so my Amendment would address the safety
concerns as it was mentioned there's
some predators online and it would just
say that these will not be a part of a
school account but it does not prevent a
student in any personal account from
interacting with these people so they
should choose but just recognize the
school's not the place for a kind of a
safety infraction
thank you any comments regarding
representative McDonald's Amendment
represent cascadden no but along that
line
my question is based on the data
governance plans and the tech directors
so maybe representative Paul can answer
this I understand that that Tech
director can allow
because they take an inventory of every
all the apps that they can either allow
access to certain apps or deny access to
certain apps
and so they watch that very carefully
so if it's Adobe then they would allow
access and if it's not Adobe then they
don't have access that's my
understanding
um that that's the job of the tech
people and there's a filtering system in
place
to either
administratively allow certain platforms
and am I is that how it works
go ahead that is correct and I actually
contacted our Tech director involved and
with this the original Waters
um and he said that's fine as long as
the parental consent part was the only
piece that he was you know saying it was
absolutely mandatory to be in there but
clearly we there they definitely go
through the list and make sure nobody's
doing what they shouldn't be doing they
shut things down Adobe is I have to say
has not ever been an issue I did Adobe
all this week in Middle with middle
schoolers
um but going back to this LinkedIn this
is about LinkedIn
thank you
a reference McDonald your your
amendments represent referencing 189
colon 70.
and doesn't mention anything about uh
parental consent
um
is it your intent that parental consent
belongs in there somewhere or or should
it be referencing 189 60 colon 66 not
70.
um and then I also have the question
what is an influencer
okay yes my Amendment does have the in
the intention of my amendment is for
parental consent whether that be coupled
with something else
um
as for the placement of it in the rsas I
added a sentence to the original Bill my
Amendment arose prior to these
subsequent amendments so if it is felt
by the committee is better placed in a
different RSA then that's totally all
right as well and as for an influencer
that would be someone using social media
for the point of making a career of
social media when the intent of CTE is
to develop careers in Industry
recognized credentials and social media
as a career itself
as opposed to not being used
as it should be as a tool to help
someone's career as opposed to social
media is the career and I think that's
really not the intent of the bill but as
worded the bill itself has nothing to
prevent something like that from arising
which there's obvious safety concerns
with that
representative Hall thank you
representative McDonald I'm just curious
does adding the approved program of
study does that fix the problem with
social media influencers since that's
probably not in the program of study
would that kind of take care of that
again I do think that's a step in the
right direction and I am supportive of
that amending language and addition
because like I said that would have a
lot to do since we cannot prevent social
media platforms third-party contracts
and how their terms of service operate
my Amendment just aims to be the
school's oversight of students and how
students use the platform so I still
think it would be necessary thank you
it's a simple question on on the program
the information that attorneys Fenton
provided at least that you passed out
two minutes ago is um Rick is there a
specific amendment number attached to
this or this there will be they're doing
it right but they're speaking could be
the same thing they have the exactly
this the same sheet
they're going to give us two book
amendments one without section one
and that piece you have there
over that piece and the other one is
with section one and that is section two
thank you thank you representative
can we do yet another amendment that
adds her language to section one
and your language to section two
I I I would say that their needs and ask
the attorney there
um we heard one definition of
influencers
what would your definition be
she's a lot younger than me so I'm going
to go with her definition
um very good I'm not gonna try to one-up
that um I I do I I don't know if it's
it's necessary because of the way it's
structured and I'm interested in your
thoughts on this but if you put it into
the way it is now in 189.66 and it's in
the approved
um program that's submitted to the state
board or the not the State Board the
school board on an annual basis and
that's what's provided for
in the law and then it has to be part of
an approved program of study I wonder if
that
addresses your concern because I
understand your concern
um and and I think you're right it's a
good idea to to include it but I think
there's a couple layers of protection
there that's just how I look at it and
again I'm going to defer to you
um uh on on what that definition is
um I appreciate you saying that and for
your work in drafting this amendment
um
in terms of my Amendment it's my first
time making an amendment if the
definitions are unclear I think we have
talked about combining amendments anyway
so we can clarify the language if that's
the issue I still do think there is some
necessary
component to this that is missing if my
amendment is not addressed the safety
concerns I think adding this as approved
program of study is very important yes
do that but in addition
we really there is nothing as the
amendment is written that would prevent
uses of other social media platforms the
intention is LinkedIn it was
colloquially referred to as the LinkedIn
Amendment but there are numerous social
media platforms that theoretically could
be involved and I just want a standard
to be recognized in this build that
would prevent other social media
platforms for a non-safe purpose
I I just assumed that with the the
safeguards of the I.T in schools that
the other social media platforms are
already blocked
um I don't think unless I'm wrong
representative
um I I don't think they can get on them
well I I think even though we call this
a LinkedIn bill it doesn't mean it's
only LinkedIn I mean I think again we're
talking about approved program of study
approved uh platforms so it could be
well beyond LinkedIn but they need to be
approved platforms
and I don't think Claudia Conway as an
influencer is going to make it here I
don't think she's going to be in that
career is going to be an approval
program of study so I don't know
it's beyond LinkedIn I think
would it be wise than represent a hall
that in the
Amendment here from the attorneys that
we we say that
register for Approved technology
platforms and services to be used as
part of the students approves program of
study
we put the word approved in in front of
Technology
so that would give another layer of
acceptance by the
the program and maybe deal with some of
the safety pardon me it's not already
yes I I I I I it may be duplicative I
know it but
um
represent that Damon
so I think that's actually a good ad
because I don't read that as the same
thing approved technology platforms
versus approve program of study
those are two different things I think
we could put approved in there twice
and I also if I can separate Point go
ahead
yes go ahead
it's important to look at this in the
broader context of a changing landscape
so we're
colloquially calling it The LinkedIn
bill but you know tomorrow or next year
or whenever from now there'll be other
platforms other social media
so we shouldn't be looking at it only
through
the lens or concern of LinkedIn
okay further discussion we've got to
move on here I think we've maybe we're
closing in on it
thank you very much that's the Wonder
just very quickly and I agree with
representative Damon it's so hard to
legislate technology that is constantly
changing
um
but I wonder
if the concern is perhaps addressed if
you look at 189 66 Roman numeral five in
its entirety look at those enumerated
Provisions we're all focused on F
because that's what we've drafted and
that is the amendment but if you look at
a through e where they talk about an
inventory of of the software
applications and the digital tools is it
addressed or can one of those
pieces that's already enumerated can
this committee add to that
just to add in that platform if that
makes sense I think what I'm hearing is
there's a lot of language that's agreed
to there are very little areas that are
not agreed to
might be worth taking a highlighter and
a highlighting the parts that we all
agree to we I'm not a member of this
committee but
um this week
this week
this week this group
um and identifying what is already
agreed to because there's a lot of
consensus I think the disagreements are
pretty minor
um but I think if you look I would
encourage this committee to look at
what's already enumerated it might
already be encompassed in there and
perhaps that could be added to if you
feel that it's not sufficient
and looking at Item B here within that
laundry list a through f
um B has
a standards set by the department
that must mean Doe
yes
and does the department have standards
for the software application digital
tools and extensions
I don't have that list yeah off the top
of my head but I would assume that we do
that we have it
so then what we're talking about being
an approved technology platform may
already been done by the department
I can look into seeing if we have that
list but I think when you look at that
section you can't just look at it as F I
think you have to look at it in totality
yes because that is it's part of a
broader policy
further
yes representative
can you explain to me
what it is in in first section
that
[Music]
um
it causes you to want us to leave that
in
the first section that last sentence
that was added by the sentence there
this definition shall not apply to
platforms
clarifies the depth Mission and I think
it alleviates any concern that
it the definition could conflict with
um
the provision that's going to be known
as subsection f
okay further
thank you very much my pleasure thank
you
so this will conclude the work session
we have on on this bill 213.
uh so we've completed both of the work
sessions
and we're getting now ready down here to
the executive session for 218 and 213.
however we do not have amendments yet
from um one of those
let's take a short caucus here for both
groups
the question I would have before you on
213 or 2 uh 18.
is it best to retain that bill for
further work and information as we
received from Melissa this morning
and 266
yeah you can go ahead and talk about 266
too I notice we have
have three bells on the docket two one
three two one eight and two six six
um we'll start off with uh Senate Bill
which we've already discussed this
morning
and I Look to representative to make a
recommendation this is an early educator
professional development Grant uh Bill
representative I would like to move
retain is there a second
represent Belcher seconds out so we have
a motion to retain made by
representative second by representative
Belcher uh on 218.
discussion yeah clearly we're not ready
for this we have so many questions about
it it just makes sense to retain it and
we have unanswered questions
it's an early Bill we need the answers
to the questions and we don't even know
where we stand if we do pass or we don't
pass so we should just retain it and
wait until we get the full information
well Sam Belcher do you have any further
comments I would just say that we really
need to get clarification especially on
whether this bill would essentially swap
out new tax funds from New Hampshire
taxpayers for federal tax funds not in
addition to but instead of and that that
would be a loss if we were to do that
any further discussion on the bill
not seeing any Madam clerk would you
please call the roll representative
well I've seen we have a yes go ahead
okay repson but the motion is to retain
representative Dolan yes
representative leckis YES Prep is
representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative petterdale yes
representative
[Music]
destination yes
okay thank you
uh representative Miler yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner no
representative luno yes
representative Woodcock no
representative Paul yes
representative representative Balboni
yes
representative cascadden yes
representative Damon yes
they're 15 years two Nays and two not
voting
thank you very much too absent to to
absent thank you fifteen two oh wait a
minute representative Labs sorry yeah
back to the program yes 16. yeah it
didn't add up thank you
thank you 16 votes yay two nay and two
not voting thank you very much so we
will retain that bill the next bill on
the docket today is uh Senate Bill 266
I'd love to represent paternal for a
motion
I move on to I'm sorry
and we've retain on Senate bill 266.
is there a second
I'll second it
okay 266 is Opera representative
parental do you have any discussion on
the bill
well as we know this bill is a huge
amount of work we've had several work
sessions and I don't think our work has
even begun to come close to conclusion
on this so we certainly require more
time to come to an agreement on this
important bill
and I'll just add in as The Thinker the
second we've had a number of work
sessions on this bill Senate bill 266.
over a period of days and the bill
itself the side by sides are over 40
pages in length
and we've gone through and it deals with
uh chapter 193
ACH
Etc and there's a lot of work in there a
lot of questions and it will take much
more time to filter through and try to
come up with a a a recommendation of
moving forward or not moving forward
with this bill so I also support the
motion to retain
further discussion from the committee
Madam clerk would you please call the
roll
the motion is to retain
representative Dolan yes representative
leckis yes
representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative pedernal yes
representative D Simone
thank you yes
representative Miler yes representative
Cornell yes representative Tanner yes
representative luno yes representative
Woodcock yes representative Hall yes
representative Balboni yes
representative cascadden yes
representative Damon yes representative
Ladd yes
18 votes yay no Nays two not voting two
absent no not voting you said I said
absent last time you told me not no
voting they're not here okay the next
bill we have on the doc is SBE 213. I
would just like to thank Jennifer for
for all the work she did on 260. and
we're not done with it yet done and
we're going to continue a little bit of
June September October a little bit of
November I'm sure
and uh so the last bill set SB 213 we're
not going to take any action on that
bill today
so that we had a pretty healthy
discussion here we narrowed down I think
we're getting close to having some
resolution however we don't have those
amendments yet and so we could be
sitting here for quite a while and it's
not an early bill so we don't have to
address it at this moment
lastly or not lastly but second to the
end I want to show you a picture of
Riker David that is Lindsay's little boy
she just had so I'm going to pass it
around we only have one picture and she
had this youngster on May 3rd to uh 2023
at 2 14 a.m that's today and here she is
already up with her youngster pass it
around and then we'll go both ways but
that's just remarkable
yeah
and she looks very healthy and and
little boy is just fantastic so
now we do have one other issue on front
of us here
we have received
from
our clerk's office a bill
which has been sent to us from the
Senate
here it is over here
some of you have probably seen these
sheets before
this is on
HB 550.
it's been sent to us either to concur
non-concur or non-concur and request a
committee of conference this is when
some other or the other side of the wall
Senate modifies one of our bills it
comes back to us this bill has been
modified so we look at that see is this
palatable to us
or not if it's not then we can request
either to have a committee a conference
or non-concur
now I'm going to pass out a copy of of
what they've done in the Senate to you
and it probably shouldn't take a whole
lot of Genius here to figure out what
they did
what does the senate usually do
that's exactly right
and so on this members of this committee
and the purpose of this bill is Charter
Public School disillusioned the
committee to look at that
and we had there will be uh four members
of the House of Representatives we had
two members of the Senate they want one
it's just a long punching that's right
that's where I went through it and
that's the only change and so what the
deal is on this the chairs of the
specific committee always come to the
committee of the whole and look for some
kind of a agreement I don't have to do
that but I've always done that I know
representative Meyer to that
representative Gile did that all the
representatives have previously done it
through our chairs and so I'd like to
see a show of hands
for those that are supportive of the
Senate
Amendment and that we would concur
and not request to committee a
conference
so we concur thank you very much so
that's the person that will get a lot of
these
so that should wrap it up for today
folks and I appreciate it we're out by
noon which is unusual usually it's about
five o'clock in the afternoon
and so the rest yes represent cascad
have we gone through all of the Senate
bills
at this point no we haven't we we're
sitting on top of one today right we
have
136 and 136 yes
136. there was some interest and
possibly amending that
um
but I've been here with a non-germaine
Amendment which I'm not very keen on
doing non-germaine amendments but in
order to do that it would have to be put
into a hearing process I want to talk
with some folks which are not here now
that are referenced that bill so 136 is
a bill that prohibits the employment or
volunteering or of a revoked or
suspended educator you remember that one
yep yes yeah
that's the only other Bill we have
so we'll probably address both of these
bills at the same time we do 213.
so we'll come in just that more one more
time
um any idea when
no I really don't know
there's no big rush on it and usually
what we do as a committee too
we always have some kind of little
get-together type thing at the end
um I was up in Quebec just this last
couple days
and and
got some of those nice pastries and all
that which we've had here before I can
bring that in but also we might want to
start thinking about you know do we want
to do something as a total group and
then go out to eat somewhere or
something such we've done that in the
past uh it's been a few years since
we've gone that route but be thinking
about it
it's it's always fun we try to go
somewhere we can walk locally unless you
want to go to one of those wonderful
restaurants up in Haverhill
it's an hour and a half trip folks one
way so we'll try and do something
locally and I'll have a little bit of
fun because it's been a long long year
for us all and we do have some bills
which we got to retain we have retained
and if we've done all our Senate bills
we can go through that retain process a
little bit in June as well
but primarily we want to use September
October and half of November for that we
will not be meeting at all in the month
of July or August those two months no
meetings at all that's out of the
equation
in fact if you come in and you're doing
some business down here they're even
thinking about turning off the kiosks so
you have to go up the speaker's office
to sign in for travel that can be done
but you'd have to go that route and then
probably in the interim ask why you're
down here answer reply to that so the
idea is they want everybody staying home
staying healthy and taking the two
months off I concur on that we've spent
a lot of long time here with over 100
bills you'd be congratulated very much
representative Damon you're thinking I
can see the gears moving
he's trying to remember there's a
restaurant in April now there's
there's not nothing in Haverhill we have
any further committee meetings
this week week after we we have some
statutory commissions and oversight type
things
next week There's Nothing scheduled
nothing scheduled and because we've
ridden ourselves a 218 today that's the
early Bill we don't have to have a
meeting next week is everybody good with
that
yeah there'll be a session
Thursdays there will be sessions
guaranteed
yes yes yes yeah and the following
Thursday as well so don't so much
no I think both of them are definite
both what do you see Simone you were
there yesterday yeah
yeah
I'm sorry tomorrow
those are for sure
yeah yeah
so other than that
we'll just let you know when the next
Committee hearing is going to be and
we'll try to wrap that up all at one
time
all right have a good one everybody
enjoy
yeah
um